hello my name is Frank shitake I'm part
of the IBM cloud team and I'm here to
explain the basics of virtual networking
virtual networking is primarily used for
cloud that's why it's important to at
least understand the basics so we're
going to start off with a couple of
concepts within this video that'll
explain well what are the key components
to any given virtual infrastructure
specifically with regards to virtual
networking so we're going to start off
by two concepts really we have the
physical underlay and we'll talk about
that first and then we have the virtual
overlay so let's start off by talking
about the underlay the underlay is
really just the physical infrastructure
it's computers its physical switches its
physical routers its just with some
specific software to be able to enable
the virtual network which we call the
overlay so let's start off by talking
about the underlay and some of these
concepts we'll talk about really kind of
lend themselves the both the underlay
and the overlay so first off with
regards the underlay we have something
called a fabric so what is the fabric
the fabric is actually all of the
physical components required to run
let's say a single instance of a virtual
networking environment or infrastructure
so if we have let's say our three
servers in a router we have down here in
our physical underlay really and
anything outside of that that would
really constitute the fabric now there's
some variants in this and there's he
getting more advanced topics you'll find
out the fabric can extend to lots of
things but for the basics let's just say
it's the physical infrastructure that
actually runs your virtual networking
infrastructure and within that we have
something called a tap what is a tap a
tap stands for tunneling endpoint okay a
tunneling endpoint and let's
drawn here we've got our top here - up
here top here a tunneling endpoint is
the point at which a virtual network
actually touches the physical network
when it's going between the devices that
actually comprise the fabric so when a
virtual network goes across physical
devices it actually needs to be
encapsulated think about those Russian
dolls you know where you open it up and
there's another doll it's kind of a same
concept when it goes on to the virtual
wire excuse me the physical wire yeah
it's it's the little doll inside the big
Dell the big doll goes across and then
when it hits the next server you open it
up the little doll and goes to the
virtual network right and so it's
encapsulation it's some pretty basic
terms right so tunneling in point the
next thing we'll talk about is routing
and this could be virtual routers but
it's really at this level let's talk
about physical routers and bridges these
will appear both in virtual and physical
layer because they bridge both so a
router in this case this router here in
the physical environment is really the
embark D embark egress ingress and more
networking terms of where the virtual
network actually or the physical network
touches and gets into the virtual
network so this could be this could be
one interface that touches the physical
network and the other interface is in
the virtual network which world
described in a minute so it's essential
if you didn't have this you'd basically
just have a snow globe where every
everything could talk to each other but
they couldn't get out right so it's
essential that we have routers and
bridges running at or at least part of
running in the physical layer okay so I
also like to call the physical layer a
big dumb pipe so basically a network
that doesn't really have much
intelligence it just connects everything
together
audience we're gonna talk about is
actually in the overlay and the overlay
is the virtual yeah stay in school kids
you know don't learn how to write not
like me so the virtual layer is actually
where I can be very prescriptive about
the networking the firewalls I can have
much diversity within the topology on
top of what is a big dumb pipe I can put
all the intelligence in the virtual
network and I can have many of these
duplicated on the same physical
infrastructure so let's talk about some
concepts within the virtual network when
in a virtual network we have segments so
what is a segment a segment is really
just a layer 2 network on its own so it
would be equivalent to having a switch
here and a switch here if they're not
connected and maybe they're connected by
a router those are segments the next
concept is a transport zone
so transport zone is a collection of
segments and what does that mean well I
may not want my virtual fabric up here
so our virtual fabric I may not want
that virtual fabric to maybe I only want
it to go across these two hosts but not
that host so a transport zone is a way
to limit which those segments and this
fabric of what physical devices making
up the physical fabric what devices they
can actually run across and then finally
our knot finally we have our old friend
routers and bridges so again routers and
bridges would really be the virtual
point we could also within the fabric we
could have a pure virtual router so if I
want to wanted to route between
different segments and not really
traverse out of the virtual network I
have a purely virtual router and then I
can uplink to a physical router which
allows us to dean capsulate the packet
remember our friend tip over here which
Dao inside of a dowel I could be
encapsulated a packet and allow it to
traverse out on to the physical network
to get to the Internet or another site
etc right and then actually there's one
more concept which is called micro
segmentation Wow micro segmentation what
is that well that means I can firewall
because all of this is really running on
top of another operating system which is
down here in a physical layer it means
that can insert all kinds of services in
the network fabric that makes up the
overlay and so one of those things can
be a firewall so I can firewall traffic
between VMs on the same segment if I
wanted to
so it's akin to having a physical switch
port where
every physical computer you plug into
that port is firewalled off from every
other port so you can configure exactly
what type of traffic you want to
traverse across your fabric and there
you have it those are the basics of a
virtual network thanks for watching if
you have any questions please drop us a
line if you like this video we want to
see more of these videos be sure to like
us and subscribe